so Obama's up there he's getting heckled
on Wednesday during the rally in Phoenix
where Democrats in Arizona Obama was
stomping for Mark Kelly and Katie Hopps
who are respectively in close races for
Senate and governor and talking about
the economic impact and coronavirus
pandemic had on American families and
communities when he was interrupted by
Heckler the pandemic also highlighted
and in a lot of cases made worse
problems that we've been struggling
within four years an economy that's very
good for folks at the very top which
that's where he is but not always so
good for ordinary people like you Obama
the Heckler shouted before uh
being booed by the crowd hold up hold up
Obama said young man just listen for a
second you have to be polite and civil
when people are talking then other
people are talking and then you get a
chance to talk set up your own rally a
lot of people worked hard for this come
on man so okay so that's that right fine
this is the interesting part I got a
question for everybody in the audience
including yourself
do you know how many followers Obama has
on Twitter
do you know the number give or take how
many followers you think he's got on
Twitter don't pull it up I'm just asking
we'll pull up here in a minute guessing
guess
he's got 133 million wow okay now do you
realize when Obama was on fire and he
was tweeting anything is it fair to say
he's the face of Democrats he carries
the most weight for Democrats is that is
that fair to say absolutely you mean
other than Biden today or no
Biden's numbers are dismal there's a
reason why Obama's campaigning not Biden
to help the Democrats Biden's not
campaigning okay so is it fair to say
he's the voice of the left is it fair to
say that okay fair enough so if if he
tweets encouraging people to go out
there and vote on 133 million followers
how many people should like his tweet
just asking a question just a couple
million a couple men should like his
tweets easily okay let's say a million
people have to like that's two to four
percent let's go to his Twitter account
let's see how much the Democrats are
excited about what Obama's been saying
go to Obama Twitter account hopefully
this uh you don't have to go fully down
and you know uh uh uh all right so if
you go there zoom in a little bit okay
so he's got 133 million followers great
so pin tweet to the top that's that's
his anniversary
570 000 likes fantastic that's a month
ago okay here's two minutes ago we can't
count that because it's only two minutes
432 likes gosh 19 hours ago the only way
to make democracy stronger is we fight
for it and this starts by electing so
vote for Democrats only 48 000 likes on
133 million
followers golod lower Gola lore look at
this next one here okay 5700 likes next
one while he's in Arizona pictures it
should be high
Adam 14 000 likes go to the next one I
will vote 37 this is the former two-term
president Superstar Democrat with 133
million followers go to Biden's account
because he says well it's it's got to be
Biden right just go up a little bit
you'll see by no no don't do that just
go up it'll be Biden just go up go up go
up go up go up go up keep going up keep
going up keep going up click on Biden
right there yeah there you go go on
Biden he's got 27 million followers
let's see how he's doing let's see how
much his team is excited about him watch
this October 6th
as I've said before no one should be in
jail for using or possessing marijuana
today I'm taking steps to end our failed
approach allow me to lay them out okay
cool guess what with marijuana most
people don't like both sides cool we're
chilling we're good 682. now go to the
next one 4200 go to the next one 40
million Americans stand for student debt
relief 11 000 likes that's the current
president by the way go to the next one
uh keep going down keep going down okay
that's six thousand likes next one jobs
are up domestic products so so this is a
picture that should be reassuring okay
beautiful picture it's a nice light it's
in the chair they got smoke there
somebody should have fixed this tight
it's a little bit to the right but it's
fine nice shoes thirty three thousand
33 000 likes you know what this tells
you
if if your own base isn't excited about
you man you don't Inspire them and you
got a 133 million 27 million followers
look you lost your you lost your
audience you've lost your audience
celebrities go through it athletes go
through it you go look at Bad Bunny
right now when you post something on
Instagram you know how many likes Bad
Bunny yes right now 10 million likes on
fire on fire maybe Bad Bunny should run
for president on the left right but not
American the moral of the story the
moral of the story is this
they've lost their voice with their own
people when you lose your own people you
you panic on the way you're talking the
other day somebody I don't know who was
it that said these next few days this
could determine whether our kids can
even write a book 40 years from now oh
and they're even lives they could even
get killed did you yeah you know what
this was the historian Michael beschlas
and what's particularly amazing is that
this is this guy was at least used to be
a well-respected presidential historian
but one of the most of course and then
you look at even Biden's speech this is
how I read Biden's speech because
Biden's speech is like this midterm
election is about an attack on Democracy
right and think about what he's saying
what he's basically saying is we have
two parties in America a Republican
party and a Democratic party one of
those two parties is basically
illegitimate because it is the party
that is against democracy the other
party my party uh Biden's party is for
democracy and so what he's basically
telling the American people is in the
midterm election even if you don't like
the Democrats even if you don't agree
with their values even if you don't
agree with their policies you should
vote for them why because they stand for
democracy so what he's saying without
really saying it is he's kind of saying
we only have a one-party state
there's only one legitimate party in the
United States which think about it I
mean that's basically Iran right you
have one party yes we'll have some
candidates we'll have some token
opposition they said there's Fair
election but it's not right yes in
effect you're saying that the American
people do not have two options before
them that are both legitimate and they
can choose which direction they want the
kind so the anti-democratic rhetoric is
really coming from the Democratic side
and I've seen nothing equivalent in the
Republicans die in fact they keep saying
you have all these people who've said
that they will deny the result of the
2022 election I've never heard anyone
say that I've never heard a single
person say I'm denying in advance the
result of the 2022 election the only
person who said that is Hillary and
Hillary is talking nonsense because
she's actually talking about a Supreme
Court case coming up this fall this is
what Hillary is getting at by the way
she says extremists are going to rig the
2024 election who are the extremists the
Supreme Court and how are they
extremists because there's a case before
them coming up in in this fall this fall
about whether election rules should be
made by legislature state legislatures
or judges or officials like the
Secretary of State who decides how an
election let's say in Wisconsin should
be run who has the final say well the
Constitution tells you it's the state
legislature it's in the Constitution
that's up before The Supreme Court
Hillary saying that at the Supreme Court
decides what the Constitution says that
the final Authority is with the state
legislature that is how we're going to
rig the 2024 election so just think
about that it's just downright Insanity
so if you like this clip and you want to
watch another one click right here and
if you want to watch the entire podcast
click right here
[Music]